[Music]
there are signs this morning of a
potential breakthrough for many people
suffering from long-term
covet symptoms the facebook group
survivor corps found that 39 percent of
covet long-haulers
report their lingering symptoms improved
after they were vaccinated
cbs news senior medical correspondent dr
taran narula spoke with
two patients who got better dr narula
good morning to you
good morning tony many long-haulers say
they're terrified of getting the coveted
vaccine
worried that the shot meant to protect
them will make the debilitating symptoms
they now live with worse
but many patients are reporting the
opposite after their shots
i was extremely fatigued i was having
these excruciating pains in my back and
in my lungs almost kimberly
wills-rinaldi says
she hasn't been the same since she was
diagnosed with covid last march the
58-year-old long-hauler suffered from
serious lingering health issues until
she received her first coveted vaccine
shot
last month for me this is a miracle
what has been the improvement in your
symptoms
the viral conjunctivitis specifically in
my right eye
is gone the rash that was on my back
and on my arms and my neck that's gone
the extreme extreme
fatigue episodes those have gotten
better too
the group's survivor corps polled 962
long-haulers
and found 46 percent said they remained
the same after the vaccine
14 percent felt worse while 39 percent
improved after the shot from mild to
full resolution of symptoms
survivors reported feeling better at
various points of the vaccination
process
it wasn't something i had expected to
see the poll
caught the attention of akiko iwasaki an
immunobiologist at yale school of
medicine
she's launching a study on people with
long covid collecting
blood and saliva samples to compare
immune responses before
and after long-haulers get the vaccine
to understand
if it really helps one long covet theory
is that pieces of the virus may
hide in the body the vaccine induces
robust
antibody and t cell responses that can
clear the viral reservoir
or remnants that's causing the
inflammation
and that would be a permanent solution
to lung coveted another theory
long covet is driven by a hyperactive
autoimmune response
and the vaccine may reduce those
responses there is no good therapy for
lung covid
and the people have really debilitating
symptoms and so
there's a lot of excitement about this
study
i was terrified of getting the vaccine
at the same time i was terrified not to
get the vaccine
judy dodd suffered dizziness headaches
and exhaustion for more than a year
after she got covered a few weeks after
i got the second vaccine
i was like in my living room like
dancing or something and my partner was
like
i don't think i've seen you dance in a
year i forgot what it was like to like
wake up in the morning and feel good and
feel
you know excited for the day and not
feel defeated
before you've even gotten out of bed it
sounds like someone just
switched a light on that's how i felt
that's exactly how i felt like
yale hopes to enroll at least a hundred
people with long covid in its study to
understand these
phenomena and see if the relief will
last researchers also say the findings
could help in
other diseases that may be triggered by
a virus such as chronic fatigue syndrome
tony very interesting so what more are
researchers learning about the
connection between the vaccine and the
covert long-haul symptoms
well what a fascinating twist this would
be and you know there is precedent for
therapeutic vaccines we don't think
about vaccines in that way but there are
three approved right now
for cancer there are others being
studied for hiv so we
these are anecdotes in terms of
long-haulers and covid we really need
those observational controlled studies
but
researchers believe this really is a
heterogeneous disease meaning for some
people it may be those viral reservoirs
or remnants
for others it may be the autoimmune
phenomenon or for some all three so
they really need to categorize patients
to really better understand them to
figure out a targeted approach and that
means looking at their antibody response
t cell response cytokine response
with those blood and saliva samples and
and also understanding
does the vaccine maybe work better in
long haulers who are women versus men or
different age groups or different
ethnicities
but really the dream and the hope is
that this can provide that therapy for
the so many americans that are suffering
with long-haul syndrome yeah really
tantalizing stuff tara thank you very
much we appreciate